how to make a million dollars in high
school so today I'm answering a question
for our YouTube viewers love you guys
Siddiqui who wrote in to say hey Evan
I'm 13 years old and my goal is to make
$1,000,000 before the end of high school
I know that in order to be successful
you need to find your passion I've
researched a lot about different forms
of marketing such as network marketing
and internet marketing all I need now is
just to find my passion and then I can
get started to move into my goal any
advice I love this question and you're
gonna get a lot of people who say 13
years old make a million dollars before
you finish high school you're crazy that
can't be done but I believe that you can
and people have done it it has been done
and it's only getting easier to hit that
goal so here's how to go about it you
are absolutely right that you have to
find your passion the number one rule is
find your passion you've got to find
what you love doing and to do that I
mean I have a zuga guide that goes
through this exactly step-by-step that
you might want to check out but you want
to find the activities that you get lost
in that you love doing imagine you
didn't have to go to school you'd have
any responsibilities what would you do
with your day to day life you wouldn't
just lie down all day right you would
want to do something so what would you
do how would you spend your time what
activities can you do right now that
you're already doing that you started
9:00 in the morning and you look up and
it's 5:00 at night 6:00 at night 7 I
know what is it that you just you've
lost the whole day doing this because
you loved it so much that's what's
critical that's what you need to find so
think about those activities that you
love doing already think about the
activities you daydream about you wish
you could do these things and go and try
it that's gonna be where you pour your
passion because I can't tell you what
opportunity to go after right I can't
say hey you know what you should get
into gaming you should be an eSports
player you should go and be a
professional league of Legends player
and get sponsorship and go win
tournaments deserve now million-dollar
prizes right but if you don't love
gaming if you don't love League of
Legends then it's not gonna work for you
so you've got to find what you love
number two
and in the value okay you have to
remember that if you want to get paid
you have to add value to people's life
somehow if you want to make money you
got to add value you want to make a lot
of money you got to add a lot of value
you want to make a lot of money quickly
you need to add a lot of value quickly
so you know you could love surfing but
if you're just out there surfing all day
you're not adding value to people's
lives you're not gonna make money from
it so you got to find out what do you
have to do to add value to somebody's
life so if you love surfing maybe you're
teaching people how to surf maybe you're
making videos about surfing maybe you're
creating products or DVDs or other info
products about surfing maybe you're
gonna enter surf competitions and get
sponsorship and try to win big prizes
right you got to figure out ways you're
adding value to other people's life
that's how you mix it with your passion
to make money the third thing is get
started a lot of people who want to run
a business they spend so much time
analyzing and researching and digging
and trying to understand that they never
actually take action now you sound like
a pretty motivated person which I love I
like it you got to take action you have
to realize that your plan is going to
change you start off on a track you're
exploring a passion and it's going to
change on you and that happens all the
time the plan that you start with is
very rarely almost never the plan that
you finish with and so don't freak out
and try to get the perfect plan from the
start because it's gonna change anyway
the key is to start down the path see if
it's right for you and then adjust so
get started and don't let the fear of
not having a perfect plan hold you back
believe
[Music]
thank you for watching if you guys like
this video you can support me by
clicking on the link in the description
you can leave a comment let me know what
you think let me know if you have a
question I can answer for you and don't
forget click on my face subscribe to the
channel thank you so much I'll see you
soon